was gilt hier ist euer marx und herzlich
willkommen zur heutigen folge minecraft
nero ja es geht weiter heute ist meine
wahl folge das heißt ich muss meine
meine stimme abgeben
und ich muss das essence problem lösen
es ist auch direkt nacht letztens haben
darüber geredet dass irgendwie nicht
nacht wird in minecraft nero anscheinend
hat sich das jetzt geändert oder ich war
einfach immer nur zu ungünstigen
zeitpunkten online
wobei es ja eigentlich ja erheblich
wünschenswert ist dass keine nacht wird
so bei dem was immer hier abgeht nachts
und das ist nicht gewachsen
baumann aber ihr habt mir zum glück auch
die kommentare geschrieben dass überall
melonen waren eigentlich endlich die
einfach nur übersehen habe ich ein
bisschen dumm bin
sorry dafür ich glaube ich weiß wo sie
waren weil auch beim wieder anschauen
und wenn ich sofort gesehen aber ich
habe ja die wurden dabei perfekt dass
ich direkt falls ich jetzt welche finde
direkt wieder melonen anbauen kann
na gut so ein kleiner rappen kann mir
eigentlich nichts anhaben ein walker
beschließen wir mal ins wasser ist es
jetzt ein bisschen stressig dass ich
hier mit niedrigen leben rumlaufe ja ihr
merkt schon oh oh das ist es so ein
scheiß event verdammt oh gott oh gott
ich muss unter wasser bleiben ist man im
wasser safe verdammt ich hab ein ein
lebenspunkte ich muss echt aufpassen was
zum booms ist das für ein wesen
oh mein gott leute ich hab ein halbes
herz
das war dann wohl mein erster tot
ja
hits wie was ist passiert gerade erst
mal hab ich gebrannt ohne grund das war
wahrscheinlich wegen diesem nacht event
und dann ist da dieses kleine ding ich
dachte das wäre so ein 20 leben
troll oder sowas und ich dachte okay den
greifswalder auf distanz an bevor der
irgendwie geht mit einem zauberstab
licher angreift und plötzlich fliegt das
feature auf mich los ok ich muss mich
unbedingt darum bemühen dass jemand
meine sachen rettet weil da war ja auch
mal ein blatt ab und so was dabei ich
wollte eigentlich nur kurz melonen holen
gehen aber die nächte können so verdammt
gefährlich sein das macht mir meine
planung fürs team kaputt
okay vielleicht kann ich ja noch jemand
wieder beleben das wäre auf jeden fall
live ich habe auch schon zu häufig leute
wieder belebt ok ich beende mal die
folge von heute ärgerlich aber es
passiert tschüss